INTRO:
We all know the founders of the biggest companies
and services in the world. Apple is Steve Jobs
and Steve Wozniak. Microsoft is Bill Gates and
Paul Allen. Google is Larry Page and Sergey
Brin, and so on and so forth. We also know that
electricity was discovered by Benjamin Franklin
and the telephone was invented by Alexander Graham
Bell and light bubl was invented by Thomas Edison
and Nikola Tesla. Yet, virtually none of us know
the inventors of the network that we spend the
vast majority of our time on: the internet. The
internet was created by two computer scientists
named Vinton Cerf and Bob Kahn, and the network
was launched on January 1, 1983. Since then, the
internet has become an integral part of our lives,
yet this duo doesn’t dominate the billionaires
list or Forbes magazines and interviews. No one
would probably even recognize them on the street
which is ironic given how influential they are.
So, here’s how Vint Cerf and Bob Kahn created
the internet and what they’re up to today.
VINT CERF:
Taking a look back, Vint Cerf was born on June
23, 1943 in New Haven, Connecticut. His father
worked at an aeronautics company which gave Vint
an interest in engineering from very early on.
In fact, when he was in high school, he would get
a job at Rocketdyne where he got an opportunity to
work on the Apollo program. He wrote statistical
analysis software that helped test the F-1 engines
that was used by famous Saturn V. So, by the time
Vint graduated high school, he was already more
accomplished than most of us ever will be, but
he was just getting started. Vint would go on
to attend Stanford University where he majored in
mathematics. He would complete this degree in 1965
and go on to join IBM as a systems engineer. He
didn’t stick around here for long though as his
true passion was research. So, he would return
to school to further his education. This time,
Vint went to UCLA where he pursued a masters in
computer science. This experience was especially
important because this is where he would meet the
other inventor of the internet: Bob Kahn. Anyway,
Vint would finish his masters in 1970 and he would
pursue a PhD in computer science also from UCLA.
It doesn’t look like Vint really wanted
to leave this lifestyle because he would
just become an assistant professor at Stanford
after graduating in 1972. For the next 4 years,
he would spend the vast majority of this time
on researching packet network interconnection
protocols and creating the TCP/IP protocol
suite. He would eventually leave academia in 1976
at age 33, but his new job wasn’t
all that different. He would join
DARPA where he continued the same research
for the next 6 years. But unlike academia,
Vint had the opportunity to implement his
research into real projects at DARPA. For example,
the Department of Defense would use the 4th
version of TCP/IP for all military computer
networking purposes. Vint ended up working for
DARPA up until 1982 at which point he switched
over to MCI Digital Information Services and this
is when the internet would officially go live.
BOB KAHN:
Moving on Bob Kahn’s back story, Bob was born on
December 23, 1938 in New York. Like many of the
people that we cover on this channel, Bob was
quite curious and intelligent from a very young
age. Despite this, Bob was never able to fully
explore his interests throughout his childhood
due to his family’s situation. You see, his mom
was suffering from an undisclosed heart condition
which meant that Bob had to spend much of his
freetime caring for his mother. In fact, this was
one of the main reasons that he would attend local
colleges for his bachelors. First, he attended
Queens college for two years before he transferred
over to the City College of New York where he
earned his bachelors in electrical engineering.
By the time he completed his bachelors,
Bob says that it was clear to him that he was not
a big fan lab work, but he did find math quite
intriguing. But ironically, in January of 1960,
Bob would get a job at Bell Labs which literally
has lab in the name. He didn’t stick around for
very long though. He was applying to master’s
programs and would be accepted into Princeton.
Princeton was a big jump up from City College,
but Bob was up for the challenge. In fact, he
thrived under the pressure and would even end
up running the graduate school’s seminar series.
Bob would end up getting his masters in electrical
engineering in 1962 and he would instantly turn
around and pursue a PhD in electrical engineering.
After completing his PhD in 1964, like Vint,
Bob would become an assistant professor but
he would teach at MIT instead of Stanford. Bob
wasn’t a big fan of being a professor though.
He felt that the job “a little stultifying”
which means that it stifled enthusiasm,
initiative, and freedom of action. So, he only
did this for two years though before he switched
over to an engineering consulting firm called BB&N
where he served as senior scientist. At the time,
BB&N was working on a new computer network called
ARPANET which was being funded by DARPA. Bob
didn’t know it at the time, but this is what would
eventually lead to the creation of the internet.
CREATING THE INTERNET:
The characteristic that made ARPANET unique
was that it relied on a packet switching.
This is when a large piece of data is split up
into smaller chucks called packets which are
then sent over the network. These packets are
then combined to create the original piece of
data at the destination. The researchers found
that this was far more efficient and reliable,
and packet switching has since become a standard
for transferring data over networks. Bob’s role
in this project was to link up host computers
from institutions to this network. And as you
might’ve guessed, one of the institutions that
were involved in this project was UCLA. Bob
would travel to UCLA in September of 1969 to setup
Arpanet Nodes at the university which led him to
meeting Vint Cerf. Anyway, a few years later in
1972, Bob would help organize the world’s first
International Conference on Computer Communication
which is when ARPANET would be revealed to the
public. After the public reveal, Bob would
leave BB&N and join DARPA full-time. There,
he was tasked with linking together military radio
networks from around the world. In other words, he
had to create a network of networks hence the name
internet. Bob would recruit help from Stanford
professor Vint Cerf and together they would work
on creating this network of networks. This was
actually extremely challenging because the duo had
to connect more networks than they ever imagined.
When Bob was given the job, he thought he had to
figure out how to connect 5 to 10 big networks,
but he actually had to connect hundreds of
thousands which eventually turned into millions.
Using ARPANET didn’t seem feasible for
such a large task especially if they wanted
it to last a long time, so the duo started
working on their own protocol called TCP/IP.
TCP stands for Transimission Control Protocol
and it’s responsible for splitting up the data
at the source and reassembling the
packets of data at the destination.
Meanwhile, IP stands for Internet Protocol and
it’s responsible for ensuring that the packets
of data are actually sent to the right
destination. Over the next several years,
Bob and Vint would perfect data transfers using
packet switching and they would eventually launch
TCP/IP guidelines in 1980. TCP/IP wasn’t the only
protocol that trying to link up these networks.
Some other famous protocols include FTP or
File Transfer Protocol and NCP or Network
Control Protocol. But, in the end, it was TCP/IP
that would become the standard for ARPANET. The
switch to TCP/IP took place on January 1, 1983 and
this was marked as the day the internet was born.
ADOPTION:
While the internet was officially live, there was
still a long way to go in making this technology
accessible to the public and that’s exactly what
this duo would start working on next. By the time,
ARPANET adopted the TCP/IP protocol, Vint had
already left DARPA and was working at MCI Digital.
There, Vint would begin working on the world’s
first commercial email service that would work
through the internet. Meanwhile, Bob would
stick around at DARPA a little longer. But,
he too would leave in 1985 to found the
Corporation for National Research Initiatives.
This was a non-profit group that was dedicated
to making the internet accessible to the public.
They accomplished this by sourcing funding for
projects that made the internet user friendly
through tools like browsers. Vint would soon
join this organization as vice president in 1986
and help with the fundraising effort. The Reagan
administration was rather supportive of this
initiative, but the real money ended up coming
from the private sector as opposed to government.
By 1990, the private sector had donated $500
million. And these funds would eventually be
used to launch the world’s first internet
browser and ATM in 1990 with the help of
AT&T and loads of other programmers and
the rest is history. Moving on, in 1992,
Bob and Vint would create the Internet Society
together which was yet another non-profit
dedicated to promoting development and adoption
of the internet. Despite founding something that
was so influential neither Bob nor Vint really
made that much money from founding the internet
itself. You see, no one really runs the internet.
It’s more of a decentralized network of networks
thats run by thousands of companies, universities,
and governments from around the world. So,
there was really no way to monetize the internet
itself which is quite ironic given that dozens of
multi hundred billion dollar companies were built
off the internet. At one point, in 1988, Vint did
try to privatize the internet, but the internet
was already too decentralized by this point, so
his efforts weren’t that successful. Fortunately
though, Vint would end up joining Google in 2005
as a vice president and this made him quite
wealthy. Today, he’s worth roughly $45 million.
Bob, however, would just stick around at his
non-profits and he still works there to this day.
There’s no verifiable net worth for Bob, but
some sources put it at around $8 million.
Obviously neither of these guys are struggling
for money, but given that people like Jeff Bezos,
Mark Zuckerberg, Larry Page, and Sergey Brin are
all worth $100 billion each, this is nothing.
VINT & BOB TODAY:
While Vint nor Bob never got the financial
benefits that they deserved, they did get
plenty of awards. These guys have won so many
awards that if we went through them all, it
would likely take an hour, so we’ll just stick to
the two most notable awards. In December of 1997,
Bob and Vint were awarded the National Medal
of Technology from President Bill Clinton.
And several years later in 2005, both Vint and Bob
would be awarded the Presidential Medal of Freedom
from President Bush. I think we can all agree
that these two more than deserved these medals.
Anway today, Vint serves in a bunch
of advisory roles all over the place.
For example, he serves as a Commisioner for the
Broadband Commision for Digital Development.
Similarly, he serves on the board of advisors of
Scientists and Engineers for America. Vint also
regularly gives interviews and speeches regarding
his thoughts about the future of the internet.
There’s plenty of these on YouTube if you’re
interested. Meanwhile, Bob has chosen to lead a
much more subtle life. He doesn’t serve on a bunch
of boards and do interviews all the time. But,
he does still work at his non-profits and is still
committed to making the internet as accessible
as possible. And that’s what happened to the
internet’s founders. Did you know about Vint
and Bob before this video? Comment that down
below. Also, drop a like if you Vint and Bob
deserve more recognition. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.